>> Okay, Michael. So, I've drawn a little thing on the screen for you.
because want to illustrate a problem. So, you see this little graph that I have?
>> It looks just like all the other graphs you've drawn so far.
>> More or less. I think there are fewer
points, but I think you're right. It more or less
looks like the same one. And, we found the
line that is linearly separating the two clouds of points.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And you agree, that's a technical term. And you agree that
it linearly separates them. And you're even willing to accept, for the purposes
of this discussion, that is in fact the line that maximizes the margin.
>> Sure.
>> Even if it's not. Okay, cool. So, this is
easy right? So, what are you going to do, Michael,
if I take this now and I add one more
point? And here is the point that I'm going to add.
>> Hmm.
>> It's another minus.
>> I can think of two things to do. One is I can
put a vertical line through it, and that makes things nearly separable again.
>> That's usually not allowed.
>> And the other one is, since it's a
different color I feel like I could just erase it.
>> No.
>> No, all right.
>> That's not acceptable. I control the pen. .
>> I mean in some sense the margin is now
negative, right. because this, this point, there's going to be no
way of slicing this up so that all the negatives
are on one side and all the positives on the other.
>> That's true.
>> It's not linearly separable.
>> Okay. Can you think of some clever way to fix it?
>> Well, again, I mean, I feel like, I mean I was
making a joke before. But maybe a reasonable thing to do is to have
some kind of, you know, I'm allowed to delete some number of points thing.
Or, or, find the line that linearly
separates the positives and the negatives, while
at the same time, minimizing the number of things that are on the wrong side.
>> Right. So you wouldn't be linearly summarizing,
separating them. But you'd be finding a line
that make sort of the minimal set of
errors while also maximizing the margin, if you kind
of were allowed to flip a few points from positive to
negative or negative to positive. I think that's what you said.
>> Yeah. And then you need to have kind
of new knob now to trade off those two things.
>> Right, and it turns out you can do
that. We're not going to about it. Instead we're
going to make a homework assignment about it then,
and let the students think about it a little
bit. But I think even that little clever thing
that you came up with, even though it is
used, won't work in another case that I'm thinking
of. So let me draw that case for you.
Okay, Michael, how does that look?
>> Well, the good news is it's not exactly
like all the other graphs you've drawn but it is,
it is very similar to it. There's going to be
a linear separator that falls between that bottom plus and
the line of minuses. And there's a maximum margin
one. So its, this seems all within the bounds of
what we've been talking about. << That's true. You're very
smart. What if I add just a few more points?
>> Okay, that doesn't
seem like just a few. [LAUGH] Wait, so I guess this is
different from the other example because where before, as before, it looked like
there was maybe like an outlier or an intruder. Now, it's like there's
a ring around the whole thing. Oh, is that why they're linearly married?
>> Yes.
>> Ha! All right. So now, you know, you can draw lines
all day long, and it's just not going to slice things up.
>> That's right. So now we have to come up with some clever way of
managing to make this work, or we're going to have to throw away
support vector machines altogether. And I
like support vector machines, so I want
to avoid doing that. So here's the little trick we're going to do. I
am going to change the data points without changing the data points.
>> Ouu.
>> That's going to be a neat trick.
>> That seems possible and impossible.
>> Here's what I'm going to do, Michael. I am going to define a function,
okay. Here's the function. I'm going to create a
little function here. And this function's going to take
a data point, okay. And because we've been using
to many X's and I's and Y's and J's, I'm
simply going to call it Q, okay. Now, Q
is one of the points that are in, it's in
the same dimension as these other points. So in
this case, it's two dimensions in a plane, okay. And
I'm going to transform that particular point Q into another kind of point. But
I'm going to do it in another
way that doesn't require cheating, okay. You ready?
>> Sure, Im perplexed but okay
>> Okay. So what is Q? Q is in the Y, is in the plane. So that means
it has two different components, Q1 and Q2. And
I am going to produce from those two components,
Q1 and Q2, a triple. So I am going to put that point
into three dimensions now. And the dimensions are going to look like this.
How does that look, Michael?
>> Strange. So you took, so q\Q is a two dimensional
point. So it's got, Q1 and Q2 are its two components.
>> Yup.
>> And you're saying, you're going to take the first component, make a new
vector where the first component of that
is squared, take the second component, make a
new vector where the sec, that value is the second component squared. And now,
just because apparently it wasn't weird enough,
you're going to throw in a root 2
times the product of those two as the third dimension. Okay.
>> That's right.
>> You're, you know you have an interesting sense of style.
>> I do. I kind of like it. Now let me point out something
for you. One is I haven't actually added any new information, in the sense that
I'm still only using Q1 and Q2. Yeah, I threw a constant in there, and
I'm multiplying by one another, but at the end of the day, I haven't really
done much. It's not like I've thrown in some
boolean variable that gives you some extra information. All
I've done is taken Q1 and Q2 and multiplied
them together, or against one another just because, why not?
>> Okay.
>> Okay? All right. Now, Why did I do this? I did this
because it's going to turn out to provide a cute little trick. And
in order to see that cute little trick we need to return to
our quadratic programming problem. So let me remind you what that equation was.
All right, Michael. So I've written up the equation for you, as
I promised I would remind you, of the quadratic program that we're
trying to solve. I didn't write down all of the constraints and
everything. I'm hoping that you remember them. And I wrote it up there
for a reason. And the reason I wrote it up, is because
you'll recall, just not too long ago, I asked you to talk about
XI and XJ, and what it looks like in this equation. And
what I think we agreed to, or at least I know I agreed
to, is that we can think about XI transpose XJ as capturing
some notion of similarity. So, it turns out then, if we sort of buy that idea of
similarity, that really what matters most in
solving this quadratic problem, and ultimately solving
our optimization problem, is being able to
constantly do these transpose operations. So, let's ask
the question that, if I have this new function, fee or
fi or whatever the right pronunciation is, what would happen if
I took two data points, and I did the transpose or
the dot product between them. What would I get? So, let
me just write that out. Or, I don't know, you can
try telling me if you want to. So let's make that,
let's make that let's make that simple, Michael. And in fact,
let's make it so simple we can make it into a quiz.